Hello Peter
Welcome back everyone this will
be my brand new spider-man no way home marvel
video there were just a bunch of previews that
marvel just dropped and tom holland was talking
about the end of spider-man as you know him the
end of this franchise the conclusion of this
version of spider-man so i'll explain what he was
talking about because i know there's all kinds of
questions now if spider-man no way home is meant
to be the end of this version of spider-man what's
going to happen with the future of spider-man
if you're brand new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos there's going
to be a lot of spider-man stuff happening in
the next couple of months but if you didn't
see the news recently marvel just did a big
preview for spider-man no way home featuring
some new scenes i'll talk about that first
then i'll talk about tom holland revealing
that marvel's basically treating the movie
like it's the end of their spider-man franchise as
you know it so just talking about these new scenes
first new scene that they released is spider-man
and doctor strange in front of the sanctum i love
how you look zoom in enhanced in the background
here you can just see doctor strange judging him
silently while he crouches getting ready to take
off i know there's still lots of questions about
why he has the amulet the eye of agamotto there
because he doesn't have the time stone anymore
but i think the idea was is that when he handed it
to thanos during avengers infinity war he handed
him a fake amulet but he did give him the real
time stone when he came back in avengers end game
he wasn't wearing the amulet so there were a lot
of questions about why he has it now but he didn't
have it during avengers end game when they came
back for the big portal scene in that final battle
usually it's because different movie teams
different directors just want to do different
things with the characters and the reason why they
probably didn't use the amulet during avengers
end game is because they wanted to keep it in
continuity because the last you saw it got crushed
in john watts and then during doctor strange
2 multiverse of madness they wanted him to be
wearing the amulet so they just work backwards
from that saying oh thanos crushed a fake one
doctor strange didn't give him the real amulet he
just gave him the real time stone but this scene
of them in front of the sanctum seems like it's
after doctor strange's spell and spider-man is
still kind of learning about all the unintended
consequences of literally making everyone forget
that he's spider-man if it wasn't clear from the
last big trailer footage what doctor strange's
spell does is effectively weave together aspects
of different timelines different universes where
no one learned peter parker was spider-man
and if you notice doctor strange is weaving
three giant circles around himself those represent
the different realities that he's weaving together
the different timelines so one of those timelines
represents the tobey mcguire spider-man movies one
of them represents the andrew garfield spider-man
movies and another one represents yet another
universe maybe the venom universe don't worry i'll
talk about that too when we talk about the future
of spider-man but what it effectively does is it
erases everyone's memories on the planet about the
experiences that spider-man had with them even
if they just experienced him on a giant screen
with jay jonah jameson yelling about him that
includes all the bad stuff that he was involved in
all the good stuff too all the events of the mcu
spider-man movies the events of captain america
civil war avengers infinity war avengers end game
so all the other avengers besides doctor strange
forget about him because he's casting the spell
so he's kind of immune to the side effects here
and all the villains forget about him too
which is what he's really trying to go for
it's kind of like the movie it's a wonderful life
what would have happened if george bailey never
existed he gets to see how all of his friends and
family's lives changed usually for the worse so
in true spider-man fashion spider-man just makes
things worse then if you remember all the thanos
unsnap memes after avengers infinity war you
have to imagine that spider-man tries to attempt
that like please undo undo undo that's where you
get to the scene of him fighting doctor strange
in the trailer and him just being like no dude
seriously stop it you're only making things worse
and that's how you spin up to the big sinister
six multiverse situation going on in the movie
with all the sinister six villains from toby
maguire's spider-man movies in the andrew garfield
spider-man movies but the second new scene that
they released here is of him and mj jumping off
the queens borough bridge after they've been
caught by the new york city police helicopter
because in all the trailer footage here you see
at the beginning of the movie they're trying to
arrest him haul him in for questioning and
that's what this scene is here i love the
look on zendaya's face here too it looks like she
is crapping her pants so the scene of him on the
bridge here is probably in the middle of all this
web slinging when they're swinging past j jonah
jameson's broadcast of him calling out spider-man
on those giant screens and he's taking mj back to
queens and heading back to his house thus the stop
on the queensborough bridge then just turning the
timeline he makes it home to aunt may you have
this scene here where the police come to their
door because they know that he's spider-man
they know that spider-man lives with aunt may
then you have the scene of him being grilled by
the detectives about the drones and he gets the
idea to ask doctor strange for his help there'll
be a new trailer in the next few weeks maybe with
the eternals movie hitting theaters so we'll
get a bunch of new footage in that and maybe
some more context about what's going on with the
sinister six characters in this crazier version of
doctor strange and all the tobey maguire aspects
of the movie and the andrew garfield characters
but the really big thing everyone was talking
about yesterday was tom holland explaining the
end of this version of spider-man the movie being
the end of the spider-man franchise at marvel
here's his exact quotes he says we're all
treating no way home as the end of a franchise
i think if we're lucky enough to dive into these
characters again you'd be seeing a very different
version it would no longer be the homecoming
trilogy we would give it some time and try to
build something different and tonally change the
films whether that happens or not i don't know but
we're definitely treating no way home like it was
coming to an end and it felt like it then he goes
on talking about working with his co-stars he says
we've been making these films for five years now
we've had such an amazing relationship the three
of us talking about zendaya and jacob babylon who
play mj and ned leeds we've been with each other
every other step of the way we've done every
single film every single press tour so we didn't
know if this would be the last time we were all
working together it was really heartbreaking but
also really exciting because we're all moving on
to the next chapter of our careers so sharing that
moment with them was maybe the best day i've ever
had on set i don't think i've ever cried like that
ever so all these actors including tom holland is
kind of treating spider-man no way home like it
is the end of spider-man as you know it at marvel
even though that sounds super serious first things
first that does not mean that marvel is going to
stop making spider-man movies it doesn't mean that
sony is going to take back spider-man and start
doing the main peter parker spider-man movies
themselves spider-man is still staying in the
mcu the sony president has already said as of last
year they plan on continuing to share spider-man
with marvel and doing more movies like they've
been doing with the previous spider-man mcu movies
and tom holland is going to keep playing
the main version of peter parker spider-man
what tom holland means when he says the end of a
franchise the end of this version of spider-man
is that in his quote he mentions that they take a
break from the solo spider-man movies for a little
while longer than they usually would between
films and then they'd come back with a fourth
tom holland spider-man movie it would be a
different director because john watts is moving
on to the fantastic four movies at marvel their
brand new trilogy fantastic four films they're
working on it'd be a totally different vibe for
the movies because he wouldn't be a high school
kid following him through school wouldn't be
like the harry potter films anymore and it'd be a
totally different direction that they would take
the spider-man character so there's been a new
spider-man movie about every two years since they
started his spider-man trilogy so after spider-man
no way home spider-man 4 whatever the title winds
up being probably wouldn't be released for like
three or four years maybe in between spider-man
3 and spider-man 4 during however many years
that break winds up being tom hall and spider-man
would just cross over into other people's movies
and they do different kinds of spider-man movies
that includes a lot of you've also figured this
out the spider-man venom crossover movie that
tom hardy and andy circus were hyping up so big
spoiler warning for the venom let there be carnage
post-credit scene if you haven't seen that movie
yet just real big blanket spoiler warning so in
the venom lithob carnage post-credit scene venom
gets teleported into the mcu and sees a j jonah
jameson broadcast yelling about tom holland's
spiderman and you clearly see that it's tom hall
and spider-man on screen without his mask on
and the venom symbiote speaks as if he plans to
go after him like he's a bad guy that he's going
to go take down like they're hyping up spider-man
versus venom when they meet for the first time in
the flesh i did a much bigger video on that
venom let the bee carnage post credit scene
so i'll link that below in the description and at
the end of this so you can watch that full version
but that spider-man vs venom movie sounds like it
would happen before spider-man 4 just the way tom
holland is talking in when tom holland says the
next spider-man trilogy of solo movies would be
a totally different story totally different vibe
they're probably thinking more along the lines
of doing a miles morales spider-man arc with a
live-action version in tom hall spider-man just
co-headlining like a team-up arc with the two of
them with tom hall and spider-man training him
that's why they probably waited so long
to introduce a live-action miles morales
character even though he exists as of spider-man
homecoming we just haven't seen him on screen yet
so for example i'm expecting at least a small
cameo scene for spider-man and doctor strange
2 multiverse of madness because there's so
much doctor strange going on in this movie
but after that we know that they plan
on including spider-man and avengers 5
beyond that is anyone's guess maybe captain
america 4 but maybe also the new fantastic four
movie it feels more appropriate for spider-man to
cross over into fantastic four just because of his
history with that team in the comics everybody
brace yourself for the mcu bombastic bagman
so hopefully that explains what's going on with
the future of spider-man yes even though they're
sort of ending this trilogy it's the same thing
with avengers end game it's meant to be the end of
the infinity saga of movies but it's not the end
of the avengers movies there will be an avengers 5
they were just talking about it this week if
there's any big questions that you have about
what's going on with the movie or what's going
on with the future of spider-man that i didn't
cover in this video just write them below in the
comments and i'll add them to my future videos
this weekend is dc fandom so there's going to be
a bunch of big trailers like the batman trailer
a whole bunch of other trailers for the upcoming
movies i will do videos for all those trailers
so don't worry everyone click here for that full
venom let there be carnage post credits scene and
everyone click here for that big marvel daredevil
announcement about the character coming back
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!